também banho em que delícia aqui no
hotel no rio de janeiro que eu acho
sensacional banho de hotel que a água do
chuveiro na direção certa e online de
chover lá de casa que parece que é o
buraco do chuveiro estou intrigado
quando fica se a saber de você eu tenho
um treino deve ser bem resultado amigo
chover vai a zaga saiu errado nenhuma
certo em mim e talvez se bana cheirosa o
banheiro pra mim é melhor jogar aqui é
um lugar que tem país a minha sala
confortável é legal numa meca que o
vizinho fala pessoal esta cadeira passa
carro e sei que ming pele em no banheiro
não sei nem escuta ninguém foi você pode
fazer você quiser doar pode virar bicho
vai fazer o que quiser voltar lá de fora
do banheiro sem saber do erro que pode
ficar só de forma que a mesma serve para
o esse não é o indicado beijar não todo
mundo tranquilo e no boi você canta é
bonito né como nas alas e da cantora na
saúde que ir ao banheiro e vi que você
evita é bonito você permite que está
desse jeito do banheiro a bota sai da
força fala [ __ ] civil j
agora tem que ser dentro do banheiro
aqui à porta fechada em abril e não tony
benn no mar
riva abril e no tony lombinho láááá
hannah e um sabonete 6 prefere o líquido
ou embarcará eu só uso o líquido
aprender isso pra minha vida graças a
deus por que meu deus até a praia que eu
tinha de trazer para levar na boa isso
aqui é o futuro meu deus aquela coisa
feia minha vida e vários pontos bom
sabonete líquido por exemplo não dá
vontade de comer ea embaixada todo mundo
no mundo a vigilante tem gate neymar
todo mundo na terra já deu uma mordida
num sabonetes após ver como é que é e se
arrependeu e não tem no mundo quem tira
o gosto de saber da boca da pessoa
sabonete líquido a travar o botão na
bolsa fácil transportar negócios e
funcional e vou usar a abrir
botei ele tal usei guarda deixou o
sabonete em barra 1 sabonete em barra já
está no lugar dele é ali e se ele tá ali
é porque alguém usou que já usou ontem
em todo lugar do corpinho dela e também
é usar em todo lugar e tocou na saída do
goleiro fosse que seu tablet mypad o
sabonete aí o cara vem com dez
aí eu uso qualquer lugar do meu corpo no
meu rosto possível até lá prudente
em outra situação de fala e pede um
sabonete a pessoa te psd se está tão
pequenininho já foi grande passado em
muitos lugares aonde eu era pequena vem
aquela propaganda do sabonete que
resolvia 99% das bactérias 99% das
bactérias é um exemplo sempre era um
menininho assim de braços abertos e um
monte de ponte para dizer a bactéria é a
mãe passava o sabonete remover as
bactérias o que significava dois né 1%
elimina 99 por cento das bactérias dois
pontinhos que eu vá a mãe mamãe por
bactéria que sobrou do menino viu duas
bactérias não compra mas somente não
presta tem duas bactérias no ombro dele
vai crescer como pode mas como é que
pode meu deus como é que essa criança
vai crescer agora mãe com ênfase no
ombro vai namorar vai dançar com a mina
não chega perto dele vai falar funk trem
de ferro por isso eu prefiro sabonete
líquido também que é muito melhor de
transportar cair no chão é o que caiu no
chão você pega limpa o conteúdo taxou
aqui já era esse aqui não sei que caiu
no chão volta com terra você tem que
prosseguir o banco terra vai estragando
a
começa esfoliar a pele ea intenção é
essa a intenção era um banho normal
cabelo sabonete líquido não tem se
tivesse cabelo aqui dentro é que colocar
o sabotaram abrir um botar um cabelo que
vem este aqui toda hora tem só nesse
aqui tem três só pra mostrar abusei de
ninguém sabe onde é de onde esse cabelo
é da cabeça da criança do comercial
abolir essa aqui é a minha vida quero
morrer prefiro o sabonete líquido
sabonete líquido
o livro bege e sabonete aqui na sua casa
eu falar o que quiser de prestação desse
aqui se fala assim 11 saíram irmão eu só
o sabonete líquido único momento que eu
acho que o banheiro não é o melhor lugar
da casa é de madrugada porque tudo faz
barulho meu deus que está a caminho de
madrid bateu o osso do pé está lá está o
diabo se espanta contigo mesmo de
madrugada foi dito para não fazer
barulho nem acende a luz porque sabe que
aquele negócio que vai acender a luz
aqui ó já incomoda luz acende e por
baixo da fresta da porta do quartel país
já acorda outro vale escuro bem porque
tu sabe o imóvel decorado tocado vai só
assim né
arruma a casa muda o modo de lugar não
te avisa que ninguém tenha escutado
ficar aqui imóvel rock chega no banheiro
pensa que é só me já tranquilo sem fazer
barulho levanta a tampa do vaso vai
mexendo aqui tranquilo ao sanfona
tranquilo até o momento o equilíbrio tem
que ficar acordado o suficiente pra
mijar mas não acordar o suficiente para
perder o sono deu tudo fica meio assim
mg ana jorge os meus o jã problema é a
tampa do vaso que vai cair bem
devagarzinho no escuro em vê lá vai
caindo assim o pim de varzim tem
lentamente tomecek no campo de rosas
rosas vermelhos ea tampa é bem
devagarzinho bem devagarzinho 11 mil m
já que os exames e fazendo barulho algum
sou da família me ama do nada ela desta
vez pronto o acordo todo mundo quebra
pão apaguei do mar nessa casa não e jm
tamanho tem uma alma pelo grande
banheiro público e no qual o melhor bem
pequeno incomoda mas é bom por uma coisa
quando a porta não tem trânsito cada um
pé na porta a pessoa tenta abrir bem
ela só vê pela prática do terrorismo
assim tem gente o elenco é muito grande
na privada longe a porta é longe não tem
tranca a pessoa abre entra e vê
tucanando tem roupa e gente a pessoa sai
não desculpa dada a sua qualidade o
banheiro pequeno por exemplo quando
acaba o papel de seu irmão pra deixar
papel pra você e você não precisa ver
ele que se abra porque na porta do box
11 assim o papel aparece tudo valeu e
tranca a porta do banheiro grande não é
meu disse a privada é o famigerado se fã
há muito longe da porta então o que era
pra ser salmos e entregando papel
higiênico se tornou uma longa caminhada
aquelas duas pessoas super constrangido
evitando contato visual eu posso
devolver o que não vai botar em cima da
dap aí que o pai já não beleza beleza ou
deixar que uma cena constrangedora agora
foi grande também tem seu lado bom né
porque tem espaço pode fazer o que
quiser
tem duas pia duas pia é a melhor
invenção que já em metal rock escoval
devotas o piloto o avô do bebê pronto
uma pena não funciona primeiro que da
briga por ciúmes culpa não é tua casa
não quero fazer nenhuma ter não dá certo
ainda no concelho vão fazer o seguinte
vamos tomar 2 escovar de 2 numa pia só
não dá certo gente para compor que é um
passo a pasta ao molhe na torneira e
ficou um pouco distante
o outro fica disponível na pna
só quem passa um tempinho o que estava
distante vem chegando rápido passar é
que o espinho
só que a pessoa está na bahia vai
desligar bem na hora que acontece em
qualquer lugar que cospe na mão do outro
é nojento o verão não por alguns membros
votará ainda pessoa descobre que tem
vergonha de somália na frente outra
pessoa que todo mundo que estava ali
naquela goleada sem contar a escova na
fase é a escolha de ir lá no fundo ele o
escopo de lei que tem vergonha de fazer
esse período a pessoa eu tenho vergonha
de fazer isso olhando pra mim mesmo de
espelhos vetores como a dengue
meu deus meu deus e se você gostou desse
vídeo que você clicar assim gostei a
quem não esquece a eu quero que você
comente aqui em baixo que nos contentar
com um lugar da casa que você mais gosta
do lugar a sua casa que você se sente
mais em paz a sintaxe você não inscrito
o canal ainda não esquece
escrever para toda vez saiu de novo e
saber e essa aqui estão minhas redes
sociais tamo junto é mais igual e
emprego